مشاهد حرب غزه منذ يومها الاول هي مشاهدها
منذ بدات قبل اكثر من 80 يوما تحت ما يمكن
ان يكون عنوانا واحدا لها وهو محاوله
اباده الشعب الفلسطيني وتدمير مقومات
حياته والقضاء على مقاومته انتهاء بالقضاء
على حلمه في دولته
المستقله الله اكبر الله اكبر لم تكن
مفاجاه اسرائيل بصمود المقاومه في القطاع
باقل من مفاجاتها بطوفان الاقصى في السابع
من اكتوبر الماضي فما ظنته اسرائيل جوله
من القصف الجوي المدمر لكل شيء يجعل
دخولها القطاع نزهه انتهى الى كابوس يربك
اسرائيل سياسيا
وعسكريا ويعيد الى وعيها قضيه لطالما
حاولت تناسيها وتواطؤ معها العالم الغربي
في اكثرت على ذ وهي حقيقه انها قوه احتلال
وكونها كذلك كان سببا كافيا لدى احرار
العالم لتجريد الحرب الاسرائيليه من اي
محتوى
اخلاقي وفي ظل الخسائر العسكريه والمعنويه
تصاعدت الاسئله حول جدوى الحرب سواء في
تحقيق هدفها المعلن وهو القضاء على حماس
او هدفها السياسي وما تعتبره مسؤوليتها
الاولى وهو استعاده جنود الاسرائيليين
الاسرى لم يعد الشارع الاسرائيلي على وحده
موقفه الانفعالي الاولي بعيد السابع من
اكتوبر بعد ان راى تكلفه الحرب وعوده
الجثامين من غزه بل وقتل ثلاثه من الاسرى
على يد الجيش الاسرائيلي انشق المجتمع
الاسرائيلي وصار قطاع منه تتزايد اعداده
يطالب بدفع ثمن اعاده الاسرى وهو وقف
الحرب والدخول في اي صفقه مع المقاومه في
القطاع تضمن
لكن ليست سلامه الاسرى وحدهم متعلقه بوقف
الحرب بل المستقبل السياسي لرئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو وربما فرصته في ان يبقى
حرا خارج قضبان السجن اصبحت هي الاخرى
متعلقه بالحرب كذلك يحاول نتنياهو الجمع
بين نقيضين لا يلتقيان فبقاء نتنياهو في
السلطه وعدم مثوله امام المحكمه في قضايا
فساد يقتضي وجهه نظره استمرار الحرب بغض
النظر عن ضحاياها من
الاسرائيليين الحرب هي طوق نجاته اما
سلامه الاسرى فلا تتحقق الا بوقفها ولذلك
لا يدع نتنياهو فرصه دون ان يؤكد فيها
احتزم اسرائيل الذهاب في الحرب الى اخر
شوط ولو انكر عليه العالم ذلك وانفض عن
دعم اسرائيل يقول نتنياهو انه شرح للرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن حاجه اسرائيل للاستمرار
في في الحرب وقد ابدى تفهمه وموافقته
وبايدن الداعم لنتنياهو ربما يغامر هو
الاخر ايضا بمستقبله بمسيرته له في
استمرار الحرب فكثيرون ممن صوتوا له من
قبل قالوا انهم لن يفعلوا في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه المقبله وما رميت اذ رميت ولكن
الله
رمى المقاومه الفلسطينيه في غزه وفي
مقدمتها حماس تبدو بصمودها سكه الى حد
كبير رغم التكلفه الانسانيه الباهظه بمصير
نتنياهو فقتل مزيد من الجنود الاسرائيليين
يعني ايقاع مزيد من الضغط عليه من قبل
الشارع الاسرائيلي خاصه ذوي الاسرى لدى
حماس وتزايد الضغوط يعني ايضا مزيدا من
الخلخله في حكومه الائتلاف وربما في مجلس
الحرب الاسرائيلي فقد سعى ن تنياه الى
تبرئه نفسه بالقائه قصور الاداء قبل الحرب
وبعدها على عاتق الاجهزه العسكريه
والامنيه لقد اكدت حماس ان تفاوض ولا قبول
بهد يعقبها قتل وتدمير فاذا ارادت اسرائيل
اسراه فليكن بوقف الحرب تماما يعقب ذلك
تسريح بتسريح والكل مقابل الكل فقاده
المقاومه يقولون ان نفسهم اطول من نفس
عدوهم وانهم يقاتلون من اجل ارضهم وحريه
شعبهم ويقاتل عدوهم من اجل مشروع صهيوني
احتلالي استيطاني امبريالي لا يعدم داعمين
له دوليا
واقليميا قلقين قلق اسرائيل مازوم ازمه
نتنياهو مع كل صيحه ورميه لمقاتل حماس
اكبر ياد